obviously I wanna spend some time
talking about him but but I guess part
of this is you are probably one of the
more outspoken people who I believe
separates what I'll call the promotion
and marketing and kind of the outward
message from the science that's being
done there and just so people understand
I think your position is a big believer
in the science and kind of the ultimate
visions of those companies but the way
it's being executed is the best way to
scrap it might be there's better ways to
do it is that fair
that's diplomatic I mean I've been
blunter online so let you know let let's
list the things you know sort of
intellectual honestly the things that I
would admire
I think the pursuit of going to another
planet you know or to the moon again is
is a brilliant thing what we will
discover and learn as the sort of
entropic exhaust from that that will be
useful for society will be huge it gives
people both a sense of purpose and
meaning and society generally needs that
so that's a virtue the talent that has
flooded into places like SpaceX and
Tesla and boring and others are
brilliant engineers and they're
motivated by somebody who speaks to them
you know as a as a good leader of this
as a future and I want to take you there
and so I think all of those are very
virtuous things I think the design is
brilliant
I think the renderings I think there's
an artistic aesthetic ethos to all the
companies that are quite brilliant and
and a lot of people say well you're
really critical about the stock or the
valuation and I'm actually not so
critical about stock I mean people can
you know it's a free market you can own
something you make money or lose it if
it goes up or down and if you think it's
fairly valued or undervalued my main
criticism is the what again what I would
call the mendacity the relationship with
the truth this is something that you
know people can't understand I see why
do you hate you I don't hate you on it's
not a personal thing it's it's a feeling
that there's a knowing manipulation of
the masses in the same way that I would
look at a Sunday preacher and there are
some people that would look at a Joel
Osteen or a creflo dollar or Jim Baker
back in the day and say this guy is
amazing and I'd be sitting there being
like
are you serious like you don't see this
guy is literally trying to fleece you
for your money and bullshitting you and
so there's elements of that where I
understand why it has to be done the
show has to go on and the showman must
do sort of like the Simpsons manarola
monorail man to get people to part with
their money but I also truly believe if
you ran the counterfactual that he would
have absolutely been able to raise tens
of billions of dollars necessary in a
loss-making enterprise and do it
honestly by saying we are going to do
some of the most ambitious thing that
man's I've ever seen and we're going to
lose money for a really long time and if
you don't want to be part of that
journey you should not invest but if you
do you know I promise it's gonna be a
wild ride
people would part with their cash they'd
be part of it and maybe some people have
already rationalized that that's what it
is but when you're saying like we're
going to be cashflow positive and we're
profitable and you're playing with the
numbers and you're trying to induce you
know certain institutional investors and
retirement money when the stocks going
up and everybody's fine it's great but
you know when things get revealed and it
may take a long time for that to happen
it's I think it'll be tragic and make as
part of this is like there's a
separation almost from setting the
vision and the ambition on the science
and engineering side and really having
to motivate people right to want to work
on something that's really hard and it
almost seems impossible when you talk
about hey I want to go launch a rocket
and real and it or I want to build this
you know super sexy sports car on the
electric vehicle side that can actually
be a huge benefit in science and
engineering when you then turn to
financials
it's almost like the gift on one side is
the curse on the other to some degree
yeah I think that's right but but I
think that there are other models of
people who you know do amazing things
that are worth celebrating I mean I
truly believe that Bezos you know and
he's not without his moral
transgressions and and labor mis
practices and there's lots to curtain
you know nobody is infallible but I
truly think that his his kind of
thinking and building an enterprise he
goes beyond just commerce and pricing it
goes deep into technology I mean he's
somebody that says you know I can't
predict five years out what technology
is gonna matter but I can predict with
very high certainty people are going to
want more convenience there
more choice they didn't want their stuff
faster they go a lot lower prices and so
all the technology investments that he
makes from robots and automation to
inevitably self-driving cars for 24-hour
delivery are just very systematic and
thoughtful and and I find frankly
inspiring now of course he's going to
space also but he's finding it out of
his own pocket from profits and cash
flow that have been generated from a
business that has never raised equity
capital
you know since their IPO in in the case
of Amazon so I admire that much more
because I feel like it's it's rooted in
sort of a grounded ethics and execution
that is really rare yeah and so one of
the questions somebody sent me that that
was fantastic was if you took over a CEO
of Tesla what would you do differently I
I would I would hire Elon but I would
put a you know a ring around him of
controls you know one of the things
that's interesting is you can name a lot
of great people at Microsoft you can
name a lot of great people at Amazon you
can name a lot of great people at Apple
it's very difficult for you to name a
lot of people at Tesla and the turnover
has been you know pretty insane and
well-documented but I think I think
Tesla needs Elon to be able to be a
visionary you know and I wrote this
letter which he sort of you know semi
famously farted at write on Twitter
which was were on your board this is
what I would do and was mostly give him
the permission to fail meaning let him
restructure get rid of the debt raise
the capital that he needs
take a breath be honest and and and I
think that would just be a wonderful
reset and and I said you know in that
letter then I would be table pounding
Lee long Tesla you know it was such a
weird thing to say so III think it just
really restore integrity and honesty and
stop the you know the magician show it's
just not necessary yeah it's a super
nuanced view and the reason why I think
it's so interesting to kind of hear you
talk through this is it's not like you
haven't invested and spent a lot of time
with people who are doing other really
ambitious things in science and
engineering right so every one of our
entrepreneurs
right is basically telling us a story
when they come in right I mean they're
telling us something that doesn't yet
exist and then we have to hold them to
task and accountable how much capital is
going to accomplish water in what period
of time and then we put more money in
and the ambitions of what some of these
guys are doing is just you know insane
right I mean we have people that are
launching rockets we have satellites up
in space we've got autonomous systems
that are outed rogue 100-foot waves in
the ocean I mean people are doing crazy
stuff but most importantly they're doing
it honestly and the day that they lie to
us about something to try to induce us
to part with our cash is the day that
they're dead to us and so I just think
that the quality of the investor you
know companies get I think Buffett
famously said it that companies get the
shareholders they deserve and when you
have a largely retail investor base over
time I think it says it says something
about the quality of your company so I
want to switch gears for another
possibly showman in another industry
which is Ray Dalio
and kind of the thought process there
where it's less about science and
engineering and it's much more kind of
the let me import my knowledge and I've
got this great you know financial
returns and and we've kind of seen some
similarities both that ended up being
fraudulent and some that actually ended
up being perfectly fine kind of how do
you think through you know evaluating a
situation like that where there's tons
of rumors but nothing that's necessarily
concrete data are proven and it's
unlikely that anyone will ever see the
actual return date or anything like that
until it either is an issue or visit
right it's kind of like we're all
guessing until there's some big event
and it's either revealed but it's what
it says it is or it's not right well
look the positive thing here again is
that you know I think there's 1500 plus
brilliant people who work there
producing research and I think that
they're all extremely highly pedigreed
really smart people I think they
understand everything that they're
writing about whether it's global macro
currencies or relationships between
fixed income and a variety of different
asset classes portfolio construction
risk I think they understand all of that
and they publish it brilliantly I think
the vast majority of them if closed
- all of them have never seen a P&L but
involved in anything in actual execution
of trades my basic view is it has been a
levered long bond scheme that is
benefited from a generational decline of
interest rates and I think the cult of
personality and a little bit of red
velvet rope and high minimums created
this and so I think that you have sort
of a McKinsey like front end and a very
questionable back end and you know
people again are free to invest and if
they get great returns then you know
more power to them and people are free
to raise eyebrows and questions Jim
grant came very close you know a year
and a half or so ago he ended up with a
foot fault you know stepping over the
line on a few things and and they went
after them pretty hard my view generally
is when somebody is criticizing you you
know being open kimono or just you know
putting up the numbers you know
generally shuts up the critics and
that's true of Elon it might be true of
Ray I don't know but when you attack
critics you know it's generally a red
flag